[Musik]
wir stehen hier nach der auch von marina
herrmann
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und fragen uns natürlich jetzt was hat
eigentlich die modewoche die jetzt zu
ende geht gebracht
ich habe gute sachen gesehen gott sei
dank aber ich habe das gefühl es geht
mehr
auch dieses mal gab es wieder gute
schauen gibt gute kollektionen von
william van oder von michael sontag oder
von perret schaad aber die
öffentlichkeit nimmt die nicht so wahr
wurde ist in deutschland nicht so
angekommen wie paris oder in london
wir haben talent ich weiß wir haben
wirklich gute leute sie überlegen die am
besten manchen markt kommt ist es wie
ein warnt durchbrechen
die deutsche bekleidungsmarkt in die
leute die das geld haben was zu
präsentieren ist super mainstream
ich habe wirklich problem zu glauben
dass die dritte gründen so an in
ventures ist das glaube ich nicht
wir sind hier bei einer veranstaltung
der deutschen vogue im kadewe und das
ist so eine der wenigen lobenswerten
initiativen in der berliner mode dass
man jungdesigner versucht ins kaufhaus
bekommen oder sei eine sehr
demokratische und witzige idee dass das
publikum hier boten kann welcher
designer in zukunft im kadewe angeboten
werden
der aktivität ist natürlich da in berlin
aber die frage ist wie wird sie
übersetzt wie wir sie übersetzt von dem
designer selbst von den journalisten von
den einkäufern der modehäuser von
hypotheken besitzern und da herrscht in
deutschland viel nachholbedarf
dass es muss viel besser vermittelt
werden welchen kreativen output die
berliner designer haben tränen nicht von
modeshows ist ist es nicht notwendig ist
so dass man dich euch sie es wäre also
zu wünschen dass man hier auf der
berliner modewoche nicht nur die vielen
kleinen großen labels aus berlin sieht
wenn sich auch größere marken hier
zeigen würden
dann bekäme auch die berliner modewoche
die aufmerksamkeit die sie verdient
nächste saison wird mehr
[Musik]